a quiet life sounds like an option that
only the defeated would ever be inclined
to praise our age is overwhelmingly
alive to the benefits of active dynamic
noisy ways of living if someone offered
us a bigger salary for a job elsewhere
we'd move if someone showed us a route
of Fame we take it if someone invited us
to a party
we'd go they seem like pure unambiguous
gains lording a quiet life has some of
the eccentricity of praising rain partly
that's because the defenders of quiet
lives have tended to come from the most
implausible sections of the community
slackers hippies the work-shy the fired
people who seem like they've never had
any choice about how to arrange their
affairs a quiet life just seems like
something imposed on them by their own
ineptitude and yet when we examine
matters closely busy lives do often turn
out to have certain strikingly high
incidental costs that we often ignore
for a start we have very limited control
over our time once we reach a certain
position in society we may be able to
shut down a factory in India and our
every word is listened to with trembling
respect within our firm but what we
absolutely cannot do is admit that we're
also extremely tired and just want to
spend the afternoon reading on the sofa
we can no longer express our more
spontaneous imaginative vulnerable sides
along the way we grow strangers to those
who love us outside of our wealth and
status of children see less of us our
spouses grow bitter we may own the
wealth of continents but it might have
been ten years at least since we last
had the chance to do nothing for a day
the most famous cultural figure in a
history of the West was someone very
interested in the benefits that can
attend quiet lives in the Gospels Jesus
tells his disciples to take nothing for
their journey except a staff no bread no
bag no money in their belts but to wear
sandals are not to put on two tunics
Christianity opens up vital space in our
imaginations by making a distinction
between two kinds of poverty what it
terms voluntary poverty on the one hand
and involuntary poverty on the other we
are at this point in history so fixated
on the idea that poverty must always be
involuntary and therefore the result of
a lack of talent that we can't even
imagine that it might be the result of
an intelligent and skilled persons free
choice based on a rational evaluation of
costs and benefits
it might sincerely be possible for
someone to decide not to take the better
paid job not to publish another book not
to seek high office and to do so not
because they had no chance
but because having surveyed the
externalities involved they chose not to
fight for them one of the central
moments in Christian history came in
1204 when a wealthy young man we know
today as sin Francis of Assisi willingly
renounced his worldly goods of which he
had quite a few a couple of houses a
farm and a ship at least he did so not
through any external compulsion he just
felt that they would interfere with
other things he really wanted rather
more of a chance to contemplate Jesus's
teachings to honor the creator of the
earth to admire the flowers in the trees
and to help the poorest in society for
its part Chinese culture has been
equally reverent towards what it calls
the yin XI or recluse someone who
chooses to leave behind the busy
political and commercial world and live
more simply usually up the side of a
mountain in a hut the tradition began in
the fourth century AD when a
high-ranking government official named
towel un Ming surrendered his position
at court and moved to the countryside to
farm the land make wine and write in his
poem on drinking wine he recounts the
riches that poverty have brought him
plucking chrysanthemums from the eastern
hedge I gaze into the distance at the
southern mountain the mountain air is
refreshing at sunset as the flocking
birds are returning home in such things
we find true meaning but when I try to
explain I can't find the words there are
for many of us plenty of options to take
up certain career paths that carry high
prestige with them we could have
something deeply impressive to answer
those who ask us what we do at parties
but this doesn't necessarily mean we
must or should follow these
possibilities when we come to know the
true price that some career's exact we
may slowly realize that we're not in
fact willing to pay for the ensuing envy
fear deceit and anxiety our days are
limited on this earth we may for the
sake of true riches willingly and with
no loss of dignity opted to become a
little poorer and a little more obscure
you